like an unofficial gag order on all
these guys they can't talk what is this
north korea
what's that humans are worth a lot more
than drugs right now
there is a huge influx of migrants
coming over there's a very bad situation
in central america
cartels smugglers traffickers realizing
hey
we can get our product and that's what
it's called the product people
into the united states and make money
children are being rented
we're seeing the biggest influx in 20
years what's the solution to this crisis
okay i'm to get to that in a second
good morning guys this is a video about
the border crisis that is currently
going on here
between the u.s mexico
i've been here for roughly a week and
wow i've
seen and heard quite a bit so in this
video i'm going to talk a little bit
about what i've come into uh sort of an
overview and then also my thoughts
about maybe where this thing should go
all right firstly it's it's a crazy cat
and mouse game currently going on so
because of catch and release you know
that's when migrants come over
at non-legal entry points um in our
released into the united states
there is a huge influx of migrants
coming over there's a very bad situation
in central america people are fleeing
from
terrible situations i've heard some
horrific stories
throughout my time here so people are a
lot of people are fleeing
you know hell let's say but with that
comes an opportunity
and what's going on down here right
below the border
is cartel's smugglers traffickers
realizing hey we can get our product and
that's what it's called the product
people into the united states and make
money
what's that are you a news reporter i'm
an independent journalist doing a whole
story on the border okay
loving you guys sticking up for you guys
and trying to expose what's going on
thanks man
keep doing the good work thank you
and so that's what makes this very
complex because yesterday i came across
a group
that you know i don't know 20 or 30
migrants on the side of the road you
look into their eyes they're they're
they're really you know tired stressed
uh scared it's in a horrific journey
that these people go on and at that very
moment
i i you know all i thought was i want
these people to succeed in life i
i hope the best for them right and so if
you're putting all your time into
helping people here
you know you can't not be human you know
and want to help them
um but then where where is the line and
i've traveled
85 countries lived abroad in four just
moved back
last year and i see the world a
different way the countries that have
an excellent rule of law are successful
the ones that don't aren't
and what we're doing is incentivizing
people to break
the law you know coming over a point of
entry like this
is illegal and so what's also messed up
about this is once they get in
they're taken care of um they're gonna
go into shelters
they're gonna get transported to
different parts of the country i'm sure
all their resources are taken care of in
the beginning but the thing is they're
not legal
and which means i i don't believe
they're able to work legally
which means how do they support
themselves which means maybe in
10 15 years they're caught
and sent home and i actually heard from
a guy that was caught and sent home
uh lived in the states for 20 years
raised his family here
sent back made another journey up hi
guys
made another journey came back up um
you know this guy can never be stable in
his life you know he's not legal in this
country because he came in illegally to
begin with so what's that
what's what's the message we're sending
to these people now if they come in
illegally and open arms but
then down the road i guess the only
answer or
remedy to that would be amnesty right
and is that the strategy i have no idea
i have no idea what the strategy is
behind this
i just know that this exactly what's
currently going on
is quite unsustainable we're seeing the
biggest influx
i was told in 20 years and this last
month was the biggest
and there is a situation down there for
many people
that is not getting better anytime soon
immigration
100 believe in it this is not an
anti-immigration
video this is a we have a crisis
what's the solution to this crisis okay
i'm gonna get to that in a second this
country is built by immigrants we need
immigration
i firmly believe that maybe you don't
but i believe we need immigration in
this country
uh but the difference between like what
i was saying is
countries that are successful and ones
that aren't is the rule of law
and not only are we
we're breaking that principle we're
incentivizing
illegal behavior and disincentivizing
behavior you know there are many people
trying to get into this country
legally and it's not easy i've been in
many countries from around the world
where people are always asking me hey
can you get me into the states hey i've
been trying this
and that for years and they're trying
everything and these are
people trying to do it the right way and
not getting access but
the people that are doing it illegally
and i understand this is where it gets
complex they're coming from
horrific situations many of them
but they're getting the access and the
ones that are trying to do it the right
way aren't
there's no way to know the numbers
exactly of
what are the amount of good intention
people coming in
you know i've seen a lot of mothers i've
seen a lot of children i've seen
i've seen some men less men than mothers
uh than women for sure
but now we have a situation where
there's so many people coming in
and these guys are so overwhelmed
that there's a lot of bad actors coming
in
and these are not stupid people running
these organizations below the border
they know they know what's going on i
mean just going down the river the other
day there are scouts all along this
river
actually kids get wrapped into it right
and they're warning
the next scout and the next scout a
boat's coming
border border patrol's over there
whatever they know what they're doing
they're good at this game it's nothing
new right
so when when border patrol
gets bogged down with a group of
migrants that are
that are really leaving a difficult
situation their resources have to go
there
that's when the traffickers that's when
the cartels know to move
the dark stuff that could be the sex
traffickers
that could be the drugs obviously
it's interesting i did talk to i did
talk to a trafficker
that was quite surreal
humans are worth a lot more than drugs
right now
so that's like the drugs will always
come through there's always that demand
here in the united states obviously
in the world but humans
are getting more money so there's a big
focus on humans right now
another sickening part of the story is
because if you have a chill
of child you know children are being
rented
again is this is this uh five percent of
the stories
or forty percent or three percent i
don't know
i can't say and i'm not gonna act like i
do know to understand this situation
fully
we're talking years down here i think
you'd have to work
from different angles to really
understand what's going on so again keep
that in mind guys i have no authority
here and i'm not acting
be like one but the fact that we have
very little
investigative journalism let's say going
into the current crisis
that's saddening that's saddening and
it's also saddening that
we have a a government that's not
promoting
or not um incentivizing our free press
to go in to really in my opinion the
biggest issue this country is facing
right now
taxpayers are paying a lot of money for
this so everyone that comes over
you know they're again they're getting
plane tickets um
they're getting housed they're getting
fed and i don't know how long that lasts
for i don't know what healthcare's
provided exactly or where they go
or what you know rent is provided for
how you doing thank you how do you tell
the
american person that's very poor and
down on their luck especially after this
year of covid
hey you know we're not going to help you
but we're going to help someone
despite their circumstances i understand
very bad circumstances for many of these
people
but we're going to help them over you
what what message does that send
this currently is unsustainable these
guys are getting
these guys are getting overloaded and
they're not meant to be
taking care of kids they're meant their
jobs are to
protect our border that's what they're
hired for now they can't talk right now
but they're very happy that someone is
covering their story because they feel
like their voices are shadowed to some
degree
all right let's add some more complexity
most of these people working
for the us government good people with
good intentions
there's going to be there's going to be
a small percentage again i can't give
you a number
that are in with the other side that are
making some big money off of this
and again very very small percentage
from what i've heard
the vast majority are doing their jobs
properly
but that also exists if you can believe
that if it doesn't get complex enough
there we go then when we get to the u.s
side
all sorts of trafficking and trafficking
networks
that are currently running illegally on
the u.s side it's not just a
on the border problem i want to make
that point um
because this problem is going everywhere
in the country
and you might not see it where you live
and i'm not trying to scare you this
isn't
scary click bait but what i'm saying is
you know a homeowner told me yesterday
he made a good point he's like well if
someone i told him i was born in vermont
he's like well what if someone in
vermont
all of a sudden they're living in a
peaceful place and you know they have
migrants coming over their their land at
night and on the other side of the
street
is a is a trafficker sitting waiting in
a car
and there's all this illegal business
going on and they don't feel safe with
their kids out at night walking around
the neighborhood which they once did
okay so put everything aside imagine
that your life changes because of
policies
of course they're going to think a
certain way everyone wants to live in
safety and security
yeah and i also want to mention a sad
part about the the somewhat secrecy of
this whole thing down here is for
example i wanted to go in
into the mcallen bus station the other
night and there's a
there's a guard out front and he's
saying i cannot enter i cannot enter
the city bus station i said why he's
like uh he said it's private which is
false there are greyhound buses going
out of there
but i had to work i had to work to get
you know who knows maybe i wanted a bus
ticket i had to work
and i acted like i did but i as a
citizen
had to convince someone that i could go
into the bus station
and it was because it was full of full
with migrants
so the migrants are going off and that's
another topic okay covid we have copied
now there is testing they are bringing
through through a system here but from
what i heard
if they test positive there's five to
seven days before they're released and
can go wherever
and also when they first come in into
the donna facility
here in mcallen it's packed it's
overcrowded
i mean there's what are you gonna do i
mean there's they
can't build fast enough they're they're
expanding the place
so if kovit is this thing that we've all
had to
deal with in this country the last year
and been told especially in california
uh you know how not to be around people
and how your business needs to be shut
down and
you know this and that all these rules
then we're packing people together i
mean and putting them on planes and
putting them on
on buses so where's the you know
[Applause]
see what i'm saying my oversimplified
solution here
is someone entering a country illegally
over something like this well that's an
illegal act
and they need to go through ports of
entry
that needs to be streamlined in the
sense that we let a certain amount of
people in which we already do but i
don't know if that how much that gets
increased by or whatnot
but you do it legally so you don't use
everyone seems to get screwed in this
process
i mean the us citizens get screwed
because they're
a lot of illegal people now in their
country
uh the illegal person the asylum seeker
because most of
i say illegal because most of them from
what i've heard their asylum claims will
get thrown out you know it's not gonna
they're not gonna be able to prove it
i don't think it's an easy thing to
prove so then they're not
legal here and then what do you do for
work and what do you do in 20 years when
you
get caught uh i hired a guy many years
ago
he came over when he was three months
old and
he was fearful of getting sent back to
mexico how messed up is that
he's like i never lived in mexico i
don't know anything about mexico i don't
want to go to mexico this is my country
so what do you do with that i think
that's insanity to send that guy back
okay so what are you setting up down the
road here for people and
it's just one big mess i wish
i wish we could have the leadership to
go
into a strong conversation on this and
unfortunately everything is politicized
100 everything is completely politics
here
and i think a lot of people are getting
screwed i don't think i know a lot of
people are getting
screwed in the process so we need to get
our house in order first in america it's
like
it's like if you're going to invite some
guests over for dinner
you know make sure your your kitchen's
clean and things are set up and you got
food ready and
you know it's a nice environment and
look we have so many problems in this
country
alone right now and if we're gonna allow
an
unlimited number of guests say in
in our house isn't in order we're not
gonna create a better situation
in the country down the road if we keep
on this strategy
this is an area where it's just a
concrete wall razor wire
and i know this is a big divisive issue
the wall
okay so what i've been told you know the
wall's not gonna stop anyone from coming
in
that's ridiculous but what it does do is
create an infrastructure so
see this infrastructure you have a road
here you have a road here
these guys can go back and forth on the
road easier they can apprehend
migrants easier and it's like it's not
like you can just get up this easily
sometimes sometimes there's ladders
other times ropes
um you know not every migrant is going
to have a ladder
or the right way to get over the wall so
they they congregate it basically makes
border
patrol's uh job much easier
to have this structure this is what i've
been told
does it send the right or wrong message
that's
up for you to decide that's that's your
opinion i'm not going to tell you what
to think on that
watch other content just don't take my
word this is my experiences
i did my best to put my ear to the
ground as much as possible to talk to as
many people to see as many things
it's not easy access out here as you
might imagine
i think i'll be coming back too because
i'm i'm i'm highly interested
and it's and it's such an important
issue it's the issue of our time
at the moment and it needs more exposure
you know
like i was saying what are we in north
korea journalists can't go into the
detention facilities i think they're
letting one day or very limited exposure
can't do ride-alongs anymore i mean
there's a gag
like an unofficial gag order on all
these guys they can't talk what is this
north korea i mean come on
like let's let's be mature here there's
a there's a crisis
there's a serious problem let's
let's try to address the problem maybe
something's happening behind the scenes
right now
i hope i hope when this goes live
there's there's been some action taken
by the administration to do something
differently uh
demoralizing our our border securities
people working in it probably not a good
idea uh
letting everyone in you know you know
that has a kid
uh not a good idea because
people gaming the system kids
kids for rent right now it's heavy heavy
[ __ ]
all right guys thanks for coming along i
got a whole
series i'll put it in the playlist below
on the border i think i did what five
videos on that
uh didn't hit every story i wanted to
but you'll see some different angles
you'll see some different perspectives
from from different people
and hear what they have to say and
lastly i want to thank
the united cajun navy now they they're
not
involved here right now but they do
disaster relief
and uh you know hurricanes floods that
sort of thing
all over the south they might be coming
here
the reason i really want to thank them
is they you know without them there's no
way i would have gotten into this i
would have gotten this access
and as you can see you know in my series
if you saw it
raul raul is he's the one that knows the
lay of the land he's got the contacts
he could get to the camera in front of
the right people so without raul and the
united cajun navy this wouldn't have
happened if you want to donate to my
channel sometimes people donate
to my work on patreon or through paypal
please don't donate to the united cajun
navy i'll leave their link below
hope you got something out of all this
if it seems confusing and difficult it's
because it is
watch my series if you're interested and
watch other people's work too
till the next one take care
you